[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui le yémen située au
carrefour des intérêts géopolitiques des
poids lourds régionaux ce pays vient
d'entrer dans sa septième année de
guerre civile qui ne fait que prendre de
l'ampleur quel est donc l'état actuel
des choses dans ce conflit dévastateur
qui a déjà causé des centaines de
milliers de morts depuis plusieurs mois
les rebelles houthi mène une vaste
offensive contre les forces pro
gouvernementales
plusieurs zones stratégiques passe sous
leur contrôle le gouvernement réussit en
revanche à arrêter l'avancée des
rebelles sur la province de marib son
dernier bastion dans la partie ouest du
pays
plusieurs tentatives de réconciliation
ont été entreprises cette année mais
aucune n'a vraiment aboutie l'initiative
saoudienne est rejetée par les rebelles
qui exigent d'abord la levée du blocus
des ports et des aéroports instaurée par
le royaume au mans mais sur table sa
proposition de réconciliation dont le
résultat est encore flou parmi les
autres médiateurs potentiels figurent
les états unis qui multiplie les
contacts avec le gouvernement yéménite
le nude elle soulignait l'importance du
rôle de la russie dans la résolution de
ce conflit
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur les principaux acteurs sur la
scène i m in its et le blitz aujourd'hui
il ya trois centres de pouvoir majeur au
yémen en premier lieu c'est le
gouvernement yéménite a reconnu à
l'international
celui ci contrôle la majeure partie du
pays selon les estimations citée par al
jazeera le président actuel abd rabbo
mansour hadi à sa disposition entre 200
et 300 mille soldats dès 2015 l'armée
yéménite bénéficie du soutien de la
coalition internationale menée par
l'arabie saoudite
face à elles se trouvent les rebelles
houthi il réunit dans un mouvement
appelé and sara la d'obédience zaïdite
une branche minoritaire du schisme fort
de près de deux cent mille soldats et
dirigée par abdel malek al houthi il
occupe la partie nord-ouest du pays y
compris la capitale sanaa un certain
nombre de pays dont l'arabie saoudite et
les etats unis accusent l'iran de
soutenir militairement les rebelles ce
que téhéran nie d'ailleurs depuis 2010
est une troisième force entre en jeu
c'est le conseil de transition du sud
qui prône l'indépendance du sud du yémen
dirigé par aïda rousse al zoubaï dit
cette institution contrôler certains
territoires dans le sud du pays ainsi
que l'île de socotra soutenu par les
émirats arabes unis le conseil de
transition du sud se bat contre les
outils et maintient en même temps des
relations tendues avec le gouvernement
un des conflits les plus sanglants du
xxième siècle la guerre au yémen revient
à la une de l'actualité internationale
les rebelles houthi prennent récemment
le contrôle de la ville portuaire dalo
d'aida et se dirige vers la province
stratégique de marib les forces pro
gouvernementales soutenues par la
coalition internationale avec l'arabie
saoudite en tête réussissent à arrêter
l'offensive pourtant une fracture de
taille se creuse au sein du camp anti
outils des affrontements éclatent entre
le conseil de transition du sud en
faveur de l'indépendance des provinces
méridionales et les forces armées du
gouvernement
l'arabie saoudite cherche à réconcilier
ces deux groupes mais ses tentatives
n'aboutissent pas pour l'instant
pourquoi la paix au yémen est elle
toujours pas à l'horizon après sept ans
de guerre quelle est l'ampleur de la
crise humanitaire en cours quels sont
les autres acteurs internationaux sur la
scène et yéménites pour répondre à ces
questions nous rejoignons gérard
vespière directeur de recherche à la
fondation d'études pour le moyen-orient
monsieur vespière bonjour bonjour à vous
pourquoi selon vous la guerre au yémen
dure-t-elle depuis si longtemps mais
écoutez nous sommes avec les rebelles
houthi et dans cette partie ouest du
yémen dans une région montagneuse donc
habité par des populations dur et qui
ont une réputation
d'excellent combattants d'excellents
guerrier et cela c'est vrai parce que
cela remonte déjà au 9e siècle déjà il y
avait des combats dans cette région est
donc une
mission a été confiée à un religieux
devenir apaiser la région il est venu
non pas dire ans parce qu'ils vivent
n'existait pas à l'époque mais de perth
et il a apporté avec lui a donc un
apaisement mais aussi sa propre vision
sheets du de la religion musulmane et de
la branche zaïdite donc il y a eu
cette union avec eux si vous voulez la
vision chiite de l'islam que l'on
retrouve bien sûr maintenant pointe à
téhéran et dans les années 80 et bien
figurez vous que le pouvoir à téhéran at
suggérait demandé à la famille outils de
venir séjourner de nombreuses années à à
téhéran et donc à la fin des années 2000
eh bien à proposer aux à la famille
outils de revenir au yémen elle
pourriez-vous quelques années plus tard
à la révolution a éclaté donc il y à un
pilotage fin de la part de téhéran dans
cette guerre au yémen elle est destinée
à créer un problème à vis à vis de
l'arabie saoudite et donc y voilà la
raison profonde c'est qu' il n'y a pas
de volonté de paix il y a une volonté de
paix qui est exprimé par un allié outil
l'ancien président saleh en décembre
2017 mais le lendemain de sa déclaration
de négociations avec l'arabie saoudite
il a été assassiné à son domicile
voyez vous donc voilà la réalité à très
triste et très dur du terrain et mini
qui parmi les parties du conflit prend
le dessus aujourd'hui
écoutez je crois que la situation est
équilibré et donc la durée a fait non à
laquelle vous faisiez référence est bien
fait partie de cet équilibre s'il y
avait eu déséquilibre un parti aurait
gagné sur l'autre pour le moment les
rebelles houthi et contrôler la le nord
pratiquement l'ancienne surface à 10 mn
du nord n'est ce pas donc contrôler la
capitale contrôle pratiquement le port
de jeddah sur la mer rouge et donc qu'on
bat pour obtenir le contrôle de la ville
de marib qui est à moins de 200 km de la
capitale et qui deux possèdent une
raffinerie donc avec les ressources
financières qui vont avec et qui
appartenait à cette structure dite du
yémen du nord il ya une trentaine
d'années donc voyez vous on est dans une
situation d'équilibré et la bataille
autour de marib va être certainement à
crucial que veulent les outils
aujourd'hui quelle est leur vision du
yémen écoutez je crois qu'ils volent la
différence parce qu'ils sont différents
comme on l'a dit d'un point de vue
géographique qui sont dans la partie
montagneuse à de l'ensemble du pays ils
sont d'une branche donc de religion
différente de la majorité sunnite a dû
du yémen donc je pense qu'il y a une
volonté à la fois de faire mal à
l'arabie saoudite
et deuxièmement de retrouver à une
certaine autonomie voire l'indépendance
et on reviendrait donc à la structure à
du yémen du nord yémen du sud il y avait
une trentaine d'années merci beaucoup
monsieur vespière nous allons poursuivre
notre analyse tout de suite mais nous
vous retrouverons à la fin de cette
émission pour plus de détails sur ce
thème merci encore la guerre au yémen
qui dure depuis sept ans semble prendre
un nouveau tournant mi-novembre les
rebelles houthi s'empare du port
stratégique d'al hodeïda sur la mer
rouge en changements majeurs au niveau
des lignes de front selon l'onu il est
devenu possible après que les forces pro
gouvernementales ont quitté soudainement
leurs positions autour de la ville
portuaire laissant le champ libre aux
rebelles houthi ce retrait est liée au
repositionnement des forces pro
gouvernementales qui cherchent selon
certaines sources à renforcer leur
position sur la principale ligne du
front à l'est de la capitale yéménite de
sanaa les combats ils font rage depuis
le mois de février en quelques mois les
rebelles houthi ont pris le contrôle de
la province d'al bayda et de certaines
zones de la province de shabwa au sud
ouest du pays ces gains territoriaux
leur facilite la tâche principale
s'emparer de la province stratégique de
marib pourtant les forces
pro-gouvernementales arrête mi novembre
une vaste offensive des forces outils
dans cette direction un résultat dû
partiellement aux efforts de la
coalition arabe dirigée par l'arabie
saoudite qui mène des raids aériens
contre les positions des outils dans
cette zone cependant selon les forces
rebelles la prise de marib n'est qu'une
question de temps le premier ministre y
est mais need marine abdelmalek saïd est
formel l'issue de cette bataille pour
marib déterminera l'avenir du yémen car
cette province a une valeur stratégique
importante c'est le dernier bastion des
forces gouvernementales dans la partie
ouest du pays sa perte renforcerait
considérablement les positions des
outils dans le conflit elle est en outre
une région riche de vastes champs
pétroliers la vente du pétrole extrait à
marib
représente un quart du pib de l'état
c'est d'ailleurs aussi la seule région
yéménite où se fait l'extraction de gaz
par ailleurs résister aux rebelles
risquent de devenir plus compliqué
compte tenu des divisions qui déchirent
le camp adverse depuis juin rien ne va
plus entre le gouvernement yéménite et
le conseil de transition du sud qui
prône l'indépendance des provinces
méridionales du pays cette institution
séparatistes signe en 2019 un accord de
partage de pouvoir avec le gouvernement
yéménite afin de joindre les efforts
dans la lutte contre l'ennemi commun les
outils pourtant cet accord conclu avec
la médiation de ryad n'a jamais été
entièrement mises en oeuvre début juin
une nouvelle tentative de raviver
l'accord est entreprise par ryad mai et
se termine par un échec selon la presse
locale et cause des dissensions
actuelles sont à chercher dans les
enlèvements deux fils yale du conseil de
transition du sud dans la province de
chabwa sous contrôle du gouvernement le
26 juin des manifestations inondent les
rues de cette province exigeant et une
enquête sur ces incidents
le conseil de transition du sud on voit
une partie de ses forces en soutien en
la foule le gouvernement répond par une
dispersion brutale des rassemblements et
entre en confrontation avec les
représentants du conseil de transition
du sud très vite c'est la rupture
en conséquence le conseil de transition
du sud appelle ses représentants dans
les négociations pour achever la mise en
oeuvre de l'accord de ryad à cesser
toute forme de communication de contact
direct avec l'autre partie en septembre
une nouvelle escalade a lieu selon le
middle east high les deux camps adverses
soutiennent la contestation populaire
l'un chez l'autre les habitants des
territoires contrôlés par le
gouvernement yéménite et ceux des
provinces du sud descendent dans les
rues pour manifester contre les
conditions de vie insupportables les
forces de l'ordre des deux côtés
réagissent avec fermeté la presse
dénoncent plusieurs morts ces
manifestations reflète une détérioration
importante de la situation humanitaire
dans le pays la pire au monde selon
l'onu
ces temps de guerre civile ont
transformé le pays en un champ de ruines
routes maisons écoles hôpitaux une bonne
partie de l'infrastructure est détruite
80% de la population dépend fortement de
l'aide humanitaire alors que plus de
deux tiers vivent avec moins de deux
dollars par jour cette année la baisse
des importations de carburant fait
s'envoler les prix alimentaires une
situation qui nécessite une action
urgente selon le lui ne manquerons
d'argent dans quelques semaines je ne
vois pas comment on éviterait pas ce
stade une famine ou proportions
bibliques sans une injection massive de
dollars supplémentaires une véritable
catastrophe humanitaire qui risque
d'aggraver la menace terroriste
bien plus que présentes dans le pays
selon l'index mondial du terrorisme le
yémen est l'un des pays les plus
affectés par le terrorisme
parmi les groupes les plus actifs
figurent al qaïda le parti al islah
affiliés aux frères musulmans et l'état
islamique dans la province d'aden
habillant le gouvernement yéménite
évoque le danger particulier d'al qaïda
qui opère principalement depuis la
province d'al baida sous contrôle des
outils alors quel intérêt pour suivre
les acteurs étrangers dans ce conflit
pourquoi toutes les tentatives de
réconciliation ont-elles échoué
jusqu'ici qu'est ce qui a déclenché ce
conflit la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
depuis 2014 le yémen est déchirée par
une guerre civile qui ne fait que
prendre de l'ampleur les rebelles houthi
continue à mener un combat meurtrier
contre le gouvernement officiel du yémen
d'ailleurs la confrontation a commencé
bien avant l'éclatement du conflit
actuel longtemps séparé en deux avec une
partie sud sous protectorat britannique
jusqu'en 1967 et une partie nord sous
domination ottomane jusqu'en 1918 le
yémen est réunifiée en 1990 il devient
alors une république sous la présidence
d'ali abdallah saleh l'ancien dirigeant
du nord dans un pays aux nombreuses
factions tribales l'hégémonie croissante
du président et de son parti majoritaire
entraîne une première guerre civile en
1994 lorsque le sud tente de faire
sécession avant d'être rapidement vaincu
en 2004 une rébellion éclate dans la
province de saada au nord du pays
déclenchée par les outils un mouvement
politico-religieux appelé du nom de son
fondateur hussein al houthi plusieurs
cessez le feu entre le gouvernement et
les rebelles interviennent mais les
affrontements durent jusqu'en février
dès cette époque sanaa accuse l'iran de
soutenir les rebelles ceux-ci
appartenant en majorité à l'un des
courants du schisme le zaïdisme
majoritaires dans le nord du yémen en
2009 et jusqu'au début 2010 des combats
ont également lieu entre militaires
saoudiens rebelles houthi à la frontière
avec l'arabie saoudite riyad qui compte
une importante minorité chiite sur son
territoire s'inquiètent d'un éventuel
appui iranien à la rébellion en 2011 le
printemps arabe a aussi s'étendre au
yémen des manifestations éclatent à
sanaa et dans d'autres villes du pays
réclamant plus de démocratie la fin de
la corruption et le départ du président
saleh malgré la répression l'opposition
se renforce notamment sous l'action du
parti al islah lié aux frères musulmans
saleh doit accepter un accord de
transition sous l'égide de l'onu qui
prévoit son départ et le transfert du
pouvoir au vice président abd rabbo
mansour hadi ce dernier est élu en 2012
lors d'élections anticipées dans le
cadre de l'accord de transition une
nouvelle constitution est adoptée en
2013 prévoyant notamment le désarmement
des milices locales et la fédéralisation
du pays en six provence mécontent de ce
découpage et de l' influence croissante
du parti al islah présents dans le
gouvernement
les outils profitent de la faiblesse du
nouveau pouvoir et se révoltent à
nouveau or cette fois il s'allie avec
l'ancien président saleh qui conserve de
nombreux partisans au sein des forces
armées très vite les rebelles conquérir
leur province d'origine sada et en 2015
ils prennent sanaa la capitale forçant
le président a dit à s'enfuir à aden
lorsque les huit y poursuivent leur
offensive en direction du sud est arrivé
au port d'aden le président indices
enfui en arabie saoudite riyad décide
alors d'intervenir militairement au
yémen à la tête d'une coalition d'une
dizaine de pays arabes dans le but de
rétablir le gouvernement légal la
coalition entame des frappes aériennes
contre les outils et met en place un
blocus naval sur les côtes sud ouest et
ouest du 8 mai en juillet la ville
d'aden et reprise rebelles avec l'appui
des tribus et des milices sudistes
sécessionniste cependant l'offensive
terrestre lancée par la coalition pour
reprendre le nord est un échec l'année
2010 est un tournant dans la guerre à la
suite d'une crise entre l'arabie
saoudite et le qatar ce dernier quitte
la coalition quant aux émirats arabes
unis farouche adversaire des frères
musulmans de leurs représentants le
parti al islah alliée au gouvernement
ils soutiennent les milices sudistes
sécessionniste ces dernières créé en mai
2010 est le conseil de transition du sud
à aden réclamant la sécession du sud du
pays l'échec de plus en plus visible de
la coalition et la catastrophe
humanitaire dans le pays entraîne
plusieurs tentatives de médiation de la
part de l'onu mais sans succès à partir
de 2019 le désengagement progressif du
soudan ainsi que celui des émirats
arabes unis poussent ryad a entamé des
négociations avec la rébellion d'autant
plus que les routes y parviennent à
frapper des infrastructures pétrolières
saoudiennes par des attaques de drones
mans cependant en raison de
l'intransigeance des deux côtés sur la
question de la levée du blocus les
négociations n'aboutissent pas et le
conflit se poursuit après des
affrontements au sud entre forces
gouvernementales et séparatistes
sudistes un accord est signé fin 2010 9
à ryad prévoyant un partage du pouvoir
en échange de la renonciation des
sudistes à leur déclaration d'autonomie
quant aux rebelles houthi qui profite de
ses divisions il cherche à partir de
2020 et à étendre leur contrôle vers
l'est sept ans après le début du conflit
le lieu continue de pousser les partis
vers un dialogue mais sans succès
ce n'est pas un secret qu'il ya des
divergences entre les yéménites que j'ai
consulté
le manque de confiance entre les parties
en guerre est grand et continue de
croître plusieurs projets de paix ont
déjà échoué au yémen y compris cette
année la proposition vient de l'arabie
saoudite en mars ryad annonce son
nouveau plan un cessez le feu dans tout
le pays la réouverture de l'aéroport de
sanaa et la levée partielle du blocus
sur le port d'al hodayda pour permettre
les importations de nourriture et de
pétrole les deux localités sont
contrôlées par les rebelles houthi que
l'arabie saoudite invite à rouvrir les
négociations
le plan de ryad et salué par le nu le
monde arabe mais les rebelles eux
rejettent la proposition qu'ils estiment
trop unilatérale nous nous attendions à
ce que l'arabie saoudite annonce la fin
du blocus des ports et des aéroports est
une initiative pour laisser rentrer 14
navires arrêté par la coalition
l'ouverture des ports et des aéroports
est un droit humanitaire qui ne doit pas
être utilisé comme un outil de pression
tout en proposant un cessez le feu
l'arabie saoudite accroît la pression
militaire sur les outils en renforçant
les raids son plan est donc un échec et
c'est oman qui prend le relais
réputé pour ses efforts diplomatiques
dans différents conflits le sultanat mme
est en fait un candidat idéal il ne
prend pas part à l'intervention arabe au
yémen et maintient des contacts avec les
outils romane annonce son initiative de
médiation fin mars et rapporte les
premiers progrès en juin la coalition
arabe cesse les raids autour de sanaa le
temps de permettre une visite de la
délégation omanaise pour les pourparlers
avec les leaders outils auparavant les
diplomates omanais rencontrent leurs
homologues saoudiens et américains un
effort prometteur mais les résultats
concrets se font attendre entre temps la
mosaïque des acteurs internationaux ne
cesse de devenir plus complexe ainsi le
conseil de transition du sud semble
courtisé à un nouvel ami potentiel
israël la normalisation entre tel-aviv
et les émirats arabes unis principal
allié du conseil de transition du sud et
le cies suit son cours la faction du sud
a salué cette normalisation en septembre
2020 contrairement au gouvernement
yéménite et or au bel outil peu de temps
avant la presse israélienne rapporté des
pourparlers clandestins entre l'état
hébreu et le conseil de transition a mis
secret selon la publication cette année
la coopération semble encore
s'approfondir en février le conseil
déclare son intention de normaliser ses
relations avec israël après
l'indépendance du yémen du sud et en
septembre la presse féminine et
iranienne parle d'un accord entre israël
et les émirats pour établir un centre
israélien de renseignements sur l'île de
socotra
contrôle du conseil de transition du sud
ce rapprochement entre israël et les
séparatistes du sud irrite le
gouvernement yéménite ajoutant un
nouveau degré de tension à ce conflit
tous les yéménites rejette la
normalisation avec l'entité sioniste
al-zubaidi et le conseil de transition
du sud représentent trois régions dans
le sud pas tout et ils sont un outil
dans les mains des émirats une sortie
paisible de ce conflit de plus en plus
tendue est elle encore réalisable face
aux échecs de plusieurs acteurs les
grandes puissances montrent leur volonté
d'assumer le rôle de négociateur comme
par exemple les états unis dans son
premier discours de politique étrangère
en février 2021 joe biden promet de
mettre fin à la guerre d'un côté il
annonce la fin du soutien aux opérations
offensives saoudienne au yémen ce qui
veut dire moins de vente d'armement
d'autre part il promet des efforts sur
le plan diplomatique tels que la
nomination d'un envoyé spécial américain
pour le yémen timothy länder king toute
l'année ce dernier multiplie les visites
en arabie saoudite et au yémen dans les
zones contrôlées par le gouvernement
selon les sources de l'agencé reuters
l'administration américaine tente de
persuader ryad de lever le blocus des
ports et aéroports yéménites c'est la
principale condition préalable des
rebelles houthi pour engager un dialogue
néanmoins c'était fort n'a pour
l'instant pas donné de résultat en plus
son amie elle reste en suspens car les
états unis n'ont pas de contact avec les
outils et ces derniers restent hostiles
à leur médiation
surtout sur fond de poursuite des
déclarations américaines accablantes
contre les outils et leurs alliés l'iran
ce que je vois est la poursuite de
l'aide et du soutien des iraniens à
l'armée des outils pour qu'ils puissent
continuer à attaquer l'arabie saoudite
est malheureusement ces attaques ont
monté en puissance assez fortement ces
derniers mois face au blocage des
efforts diplomatiques de washington ait
d'autres l'onu cherche donc une porte
sortie ainsi en novembre le représentant
spécial de l'onu se rend à moscou pour
discuter du yémen
les relations de longue date entre la
russie et la multitude d'acteurs au
yémen et son soutien aux efforts de
l'onu sont cruciaux pour amener le yémen
un règlement pacifique de fait moscou
réussi à maintenir des contacts amicaux
avec les rebelles houthi et l'iran tout
comme avec le gouvernement yéménite et
les saoudiens comment donc enclenché la
réconciliation au yémen est il possible
d'alléger la situation humanitaire tant
que le conflit se prolonge pour y voir
plus clair nous revenons vers gérard
vespière directeur de recherche à la
fondation d'études pour le moyen-orient
monsieur v sperme quel est le rôle du
conseil de transition du sud aujourd'hui
est il devenu un acteur incontournable
sur l'échiquier yéménite écoutez le le
rôle de ce conseil de transition du sud
s'appuie sur la ville d'aden donc port
autres combien stratégique
population d'environ un million
d'habitants avec donc tout le flux de
richesse qui passe par un port il y a
donc là des ressources importantes pour
cette partie du yémen et donc à pour un
mouvement politique qui s'appuie sur ce
point très fort et il y a effectivement
une volonté de la part de ce conseil
n'est ce pas d'avoir une certaine
distance différence par rapport au
gouvernement légal toujours reconnu par
plus de cinquante états dans le monde a
mené par le président a dit réfugié ou
en arabie saoudite
et donc on comprend mieux l'implication
de l'arabie saoudite à cet égard est
donc le conseil du sud et bien soit
aussi une certaine distance vis-à-vis
des frères musulmans donc il y à allah
ou un axe de différence important d'un
point de vue politique intérieure et
voilà ce qui explique ce le point fort à
la fois ressources volonté politique et
donc d'être un élément d'équilibré entre
les rebelles houthi et le gouvernement
officiel en place pourquoi la coalition
de l'arabie saoudite n'a t'elle pas
réussi à écraser les forces site selon
vous
écoutez je crois que les questions
militaires sont souvent très simple
n'est-ce pas vous ne pouvez pas gagner
une guerre vous ne pouvez pas gagner une
bataille si vous n'avez pas de troupes
au sol or effectivement le gouvernement
légal a accès à tout jouera une partie
de son armée mais l'arabie saoudite n'a
jamais mobilisé de soldats saoudiens au
sol ou yémen il s'agit d'une assistance
militaire d'une assistance financière
d'une assistance aérienne d'intervention
donc rapidement mais là vous n'avez pas
la possibilité de vaincre au sol or dans
une guerre c'est toujours celui qui
possède la terre qui a le contrôle du
sol qui peut gagner la bataille d'offres
ce qui explique aussi à cet équilibre à
l'arabie saoudite domine dans les airs
mais n'a pas les moyens d'intervenir au
sol n'a pas le sou et politique de le
faire enfin qui pourrait jouer le rôle
de médiateur dans ce conflit
et voyez-vous le bout de cette guerre
écoutez la médiation elle dépend de
trois structures a premièrement les
belligérants eux mêmes et comme il
apparaît dans notre entretien n'est ce
pas il ya deux puissances régionales qui
tiennent ce conflit d'un côté l'iran et
de l'autre côté l'arabie saoudite donc
il appartient à ces deux belligérants de
mettre un terme à cette situation et des
contacts entre entre l'arabie saoudite
et téhéran ont commencé à
avoir lieu et figurez-vous à bagdad donc
nos intérêts a envoyé vous allez cui
distant est aussi proche et régionales
donc ça va dépendre un du suivi de ces
contacts ont lieu entre les deux pays
deuxièmement il ya la structure owni
onusienne et il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup
d'efforts politiques a beaucoup
d'efforts aussi humanitaire de la part
de l'onu et du world food program du
programme d'alimentaire a donc il ya le
l'envoyé spécial de l'onu et puis
troisièmement il bien il ya des états
qui contribuent il ya eu d un accord à
stockholm dont vous voyez vous la
scandinavie la suède a joué un rôle
aussi dans la résolution de ce conflit
donc les belligérants le nu et des
opportunités à de négociations avec des
pays tiers merci beaucoup monsieur
vespière pour cet éclairage je rappelle
gérard vespière directeur de recherche à
la fondation d'études pour le
moyen-orient était aujourd'hui avec nous
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial à
bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]